uh you know martin you've you've worked
together a few times haven't you
a couple of survivors in love actually
love actually when we didn't actually
meet you no there no i didn't tell you
we didn't you were a different seat no
you didn't meet anyone really
no um and
the debt oh my god with that's right
some other people who i can't remember
yeah
i should just say i was in the debt
we're very good at this yeah yeah
i wasn't
[Laughter]
it was many decades ago it was 20 years
ago
yeah wow yeah and was love actually on
this christmas present it was it must
have been somewhere yeah here it's a big
deal in america it's an even bigger deal
it's it it's i mean massive did i hear a
yes
yeah right no it's like it's it's very
popular here but in america it's like a
serious business i've been asked in
america if i've ever done anything else
i think genuinely 20 years big yeah
hello
this lovely couple came up to me i can't
remember which american airport and said
um we really loved you in love actually
it was amazing it's one of our favorite
films have you ever done anything else i
was like why are you little
and it's a very big deal though
i love that worrying about you
yeah exactly yeah
why why did nothing else happen
[Music]
you